et pourra discuter on va parler avec
louis hébert professeur titulaire en
stratégie les affaires à hec montréal
qui est avec nous bonjour monsieur
hébert
oui bonsoir côté on vous invitez car il
ya eu quand même lors des dernières
semaines tellement de rebondissements
dans ce dossier vous allez nous aider à
défricher tout ça d'abord résumé nous
brièvement les dernières étapes qui ont
mené à cette offre qui est acceptée des
créanciers ouais et où on peut faire un
résumé et en plus ce n'est pas terminé
encore un
voilà ça peut devenir une saga dans
quelques dans quelques semaines mais
qu'est ce qui est arrivé et ce à
seulement les difficultés du c'est en
fait la situation d'ici pour changer
lorsque le fondateur a décidé de vendre
l'entreprise
un groupe d'investisseurs privés y avait
un émissaire américain investisseur
chinois et la caisse dakar des dépôts et
puis notamment l'investisseur avant que
tpg l'abaisser américain les
investisseurs chinois ont suivi une très
une stratégie traditionnelle
investisseurs privés c'est à dire qu'ils
ont bien peu de capital dans
l'entreprise pour vont l'acheter mais
ont surtout ils sont surtout payés
l'achat à partir de la dette et à partir
de ce moment là le sud soleil a une tête
à supporter ça a à voir aussi important
pour une entreprise comme le soleil
qu'est ce que ça fait c'est que tout
l'argent qu'on peut gêner récemment ben
voilà et on sait qu il à paris mais
également il fait monsieur hébert la
pandémie et ça fragilise encore plus
donc la santé financière de l'entreprise
en fait c'est qu'un tel scénario
lorsqu'on finances avec par le biais de
ladite à une telle hauteur c'est qu'on a
essayé scénario optimiste
on espère que tout est lié et sous des
masses les choses vont moins bien et
l'offre en plus on a une crise mais
soudainement le montage financier qu'on
avait développé est invivable et est
ainsi et ne peut pas être supportée
échos soutenable est là et le soleil
s'est retrouvé comme on dit en faillite
c'est à dire est capable de rencontrer
ses obligations de paiement tête voilà
et on s'est adjugé plus de 1 milliard de
dollars
récemment vous posez la question
monsieur mba pour vous ce que c'est une
bonne nouvelle aujourd'hui cette offre
d'achat des créanciers oui c'est une
bonne nouvelle parce que ça
fait relativement rapidement parce que
dans ces chemins lorsqu'une entreprise
se protège de ses créanciers qui est un
processus qui est organisée si on veut
pas sacré non plus on veut ça assez
rapidement parce qu'on veut surtout que
l'entreprise que ce redémarrer ses
activités de manière de manière normale
mais ce contexte pandémie qui est encore
un obstacle mais on veut que
l'organisation sera retombée sur ses
pieds pu se reprendre ses activités
aussi rapidement que possible qu'on veut
aussi que la propriété donc la
gouvernance à lui la direction de
l'entreprise soit clarifiée parce que
l'actuel manceron seulement mais ce qui
les propriétaires savaient qu'ils les
gestionnaires qu'est ce qui va arriver
avec les activités du beaucoup
d'incertitudes donc des moments où on
réussit à fond et clarifier la propriété
on risque de pouvoir clarifier la
gouvernance et la stratégie de
l'entreprise et de travailler pour
remettre l'organisation en opération
aussi rapidement possible bien s'ils
sont contaminés
oui avec cette offre on se fait
maintenant donc on le détail est juste
avant les contribuables québécois
n'auraient pas à contribuer donc
financièrement la relance d'entreprises
est obèse frais également face à porter
des frais la dette à 300 millions $
oui d'autant plus que les clients
n'étant tout les créanciers qui le dont
l'offre a été acceptée avait racheté une
partie 7 et 9 à très très bon goût ce
qui fait que pour us et une bonne
affaire de se retrouver 100% pur par an
fait de facto propriétaire du soleil qui
ont appris qu'ils sont tous et qui sont
toutes très raisonnable et s'ils avaient
la possibilité de pouvoir investir pour
redémarrer les les activités du site
mais sur des perdants de ce côté dans ce
contexte là ce sont les investisseurs
tpg l'investisseur chinois et la caisse
des dépôts qui 11
de toute évidence perdu leur maison oui
parce que la proposition est
complètement le carpe est à l'heure
actuelle l'homme est exactement il sans
doute encore des possibilités parce que
les créanciers actuellement son
propriétaire à 100% de l'équité mais il
pourrait décider de vendre une partie
s'était quitté la à d'autres à d'autres
avaient sabré les empêche de faire des
îles sans doute que ça fera partie des
négociations
pas seulement avec les actionnaires
actuels mais aussi avec peut-être
d'autres actionnaires potentiels comme
quebecor oui je parle et quebecor et là
ça empêche pas parce que faut que les
gens comprennent très bien vous l'avais
dit dès le départ ça pourrait devenir
une saga alors c'est peut-être le début
de quelque chose il rien qui empêche
actuellement donc d'autres groupes de
lever la main d'oeuvre moi aussi je
serais intéressé par le cirque puis vous
avez justement nommée quebecor
oui il faudra que les u9
significativement supérieure à celle là
celle qui a été acceptée puisque l'offre
qui est quand même raisonnable puis de
bien en fait bien ficelé donc faudrait
qu'on arrive avec une offre nettement se
maintenant supérieur il pourrait y avoir
aussi un outil de négociation c'est une
négociation avec les créanciers actuels
ils pourraient accéder à accepter de
céder une partie de leurs actions de la
réputée pour pour un prix intéressant
ce qui pourrait permettre un ajustement
à d'autres entreprises de devenir
copropriétaire du soleil crever dans ce
contexte là tant les créanciers que les
investisseurs potentiels ce qu'ils
veulent faire ce qu'ils veulent avoir un
bon prix puis veulent faire des chichis
est ce que cherche un retour sur
investissement voilà et est-ce que ça
risque pas d'être difficile justement
avec le contexte actuel lorsqu'on sait
que bon la pandémie ces lois de tout
contrôle on ne sait pas quand il y aura
un vaccin pour les entreprises de
divertissement on sait que les deux
prochaines années peut être même les
trois prochaines années ça risque d'être
difficile
et oui ça c'est difficile mais ça
faisait quand même plus facile avec une
dette de 300 quelques milliers aucun
milliards actuellement 5 milliards et et
ses cinq fois moins donc même si les
revenus sont faibles
l'entreprise soit sans doute capable
d'honorer ses engagements c'est ça la
bonne nouvelle mais aussi je pense que
il faut que le site du soleil soit ça
peut forcer des serrures et a ici de se
renouveler
essayer de revoir son modèle d'affaires
à réduire son risque savez deux
indépendants sur quelques quelques
spectacles on espérait un développement
en asie mais ça me plus ou moins bien
fonctionné on est encore très dépendants
du marché du marché américain et puis
des spectacles en amérique du nord d'une
solution à mesure en europe mais il
semble que questionnement nécessaires
pour voir ce qu'est ce qu'on est capable
de faire pour renouveler l'offre du
cirque du soleil on vous avoir le temps
parce qu'avant que les activités
redémarrent comme auparavant soit
prendre un certain temps donc
et parce que ça va prendre un certain
temps que ça prend une structure
financière qui est suffisamment légère
pour permettre à l'entreprise de
fonctionner manière manière raisonnée
avec encore beaucoup d'incertitudes
merci beaucoup monsieur ben c'est vrai
que nature